[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to our Cloud OnAir
webinar from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Priyanka
Vergadia, and today I
will be taking Lisa with us and
talking about Machine Learning
101.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer your--
answer your questions
during and after.
So with that, let's get started.
Lisa, over to you.
LISA QUERA: Hi, I'm
Lisa Quera, and I'm
a Machine Learning Specialist in
the customer engineering team.
And hopefully, what we'll
accomplish together today
is a sense of what
machine learning is,
what are some of the decision
parameters around it,
and how you can make it
useful in your business
processes to solve problems
and capture opportunities.
The first thing we need to
do is establish some terms.
So artificial intelligence
is the science
to make things smart.
So I often actually prefer the
term "augmented intelligence,"
because you're adding a
layer of smartness to things.
Machine learning is a
way of teaching machines
how to solve problems
on their own.
You're enabling them
to learn and be smart.
And then deep
learning is a subset
of that, which is
some techniques
to do machine learning.
Now this is the
really important part
is that this is a new paradigm.
We've spent decades, in
a very controlled way,
teaching computers in a very
explicit rules with programming
language.
The new paradigm is to help the
machine learn from examples,
so we're not controlling
it from the top down.
We're letting patterns and rules
emerge from the data itself.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So Lisa, this
sounds really, really simple
when I look at it
in this example.
Is it really that simple?
LISA QUERA: No, it's not.
There are several deep
learning approaches
that can get pretty technical.
Today, because we have
such a diverse audience,
we're going to do
our best to make sure
that what we're talking about
is accessible to everyone
and is applicable
across industries.
So let's first look at
supervised learning,
which is probably the most
common thing that people
understand.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Are we going to look
at an example, an exciting one?
LISA QUERA: I am going to use
one of my favorite examples,
because--
I'm going to use training a dog.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, yeah.
LISA QUERA: Because
it's actually not
so different for a dog to
learn from a machine to learn,
and you'll see why
pretty quickly.
With supervised learning,
what you're doing
is you're providing input
and output examples,
so you're not only
providing the input data,
but you're also providing
the targets that
is associated with that.
Now if you think about applying
that to training a dog,
you help the dog understand the
connection between a command
and an action.
And when they-- you make it
very explicit, so you tell them,
"sit," and then when they
sit, they get a treat.
So they make that very explicit
connection between the command
and the target action.
And you do that over
many, many, many examples.
And you guide them
along the way.
As they get close to it,
you give them feedback,
and you help them adjust
to creating that outcome.
Now unsupervised-- if you think
about how supervised learning,
you can probably guess
how unsupervised learning
works is you have the data, but
you don't provide those labels.
You don't provide that target.
Now, again, think about
how a dog might learn.
A dog can learn
from observing you.
They watch you day
in and day out,
and they observe from those
examples of your behavior
and come to their own ability
to predict what comes next.
So if I pick up my
keys and the leash,
he gets excited, because
he's able to predict
that he gets to come.
But if I pick up the keys,
and I don't pick up the leash,
you can see from
the body language
that he has predicted
he has to stay home.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah, sad.
LISA QUERA: Now we
didn't teach him that.
That was something he learned.
It was unsupervised
learning from observations
of data points.
Now reinforcement learning
is a little bit more
like supervised learning,
except that the reward is
delayed over time.
So in reinforcement
learning, you have a state,
you have actions, and then
you have a delayed reward.
So we're going to stick
with training our dog,
and this time,
we're going to train
our dog on a full
obstacle course instead
of a single command.
So as the dog is running through
and having a point of being,
a state at any point in time
along the obstacle course,
we provide verbal feedback for
either doing the next action,
being a legal action
or an illegal action
along the course.
And we guide them with
that verbal feedback
until they get to the win at the
end, when they get that reward.
So reinforcement learning is
feedback guided along the way
until you get to the
successful outcome,
but that successful
outcome is delayed a bit.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
Makes sense.
LISA QUERA: Now we use machine
learning in everything we do.
Sundar calls us an
AI-first company,
and what he means
by that is that we
try to use machine learning
in every possible way
to enhance our
customer experiences
and make our products better.
And so if we think about
some of the techniques
that we just talked about
and how they might show up
in some of our products--
let's take Google Photos.
Would that be supervised or
unsupervised, do you think?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Supervised,
because it's got labels.
LISA QUERA: Exactly.
When you upload your
image, and we automatically
suggest labels for you,
that's because we trained it
on a data set of hundreds
of millions of images
with the associated labels.
And so that's able
to be able to--
I think there's what?
20,000 labels that we
associated with that,
so it's able to make your
life easier by having
the machine take on that load.
Now Gmail, Smart Reply--
what do you think?
Supervised or unsupervised?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That is unsupervised,
because there must be
a large amount of data
that it's looking at,
and then not just data
from my emails and my
replies, but also from all
the other emails and
replies, and then identifying
what are the different-- what
are the patterns on the reply?
So I would say unsupervised.
LISA QUERA: Exactly.
It's identifying patterns
from massive amounts of data,
because trying to come up
with the input-output examples
for every possible
permutation of language
would be really hard.
So that's a great example of
using unsupervised learning.
And then everyone's pretty
aware of the big AlphaGo
win against Lee Se-Dol with
the global champion in Go,
and the AlphaGo won
four out of five games.
And it did that by playing
hundreds of millions of games
and getting feedback
along that process.
But we don't just use
it in our own products.
But we use these
models together,
so one input is often the
output to another model,
because a model solves
one problem really well.
But most business processes have
multiple tasks along the way.
So you have to have
models work together,
and here's a great example
of the Vision API being
used to capture the
text from an image,
and then passing that to another
model with the Translate API
to convert that text
to another language.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I
just had a question.
Can you combine--
like in this case,
we're combining two
models together.
How many of these models can
you actually combine together?
Is there a limit on this?
LISA QUERA: The limit wouldn't
be from a machine learning
perspective.
The limit would
actually probably
be more from your
infrastructure perspective,
so the networking or the
compute power behind it
to pass those inputs and
outputs along the process,
so how long would that chain be?
So if you needed fast
latency, then you'd
probably have to limit the
number of models that you use.
But that's not a machine
learning question.
That's more of an
infrastructure question.
So you just have to think
through your business process
and think, which tasks can the
machine enhance along the way?
But we're also using
machine learning to help
other people do amazing things.
It's not just about
products and services.
It's also about trying to use
machine learning to make things
better for people.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, so this one's
actually really close to my
heart, because I'm from India,
and I have seen a lot
of rural places in India
that do not have access to
doctors or, say, good doctors.
But what Google
Brain has done is
they've built this software
based on machine learning,
and there's this model
that identifies--
when you feed retina
scans to this model,
it identifies a disease
that leads to diabetes.
And that eventually leads to
people not being able to see,
so that is pretty huge.
So this model can take
these retinal scans
and identify whether
somebody has that disease
or has indicators of
that disease, and then
at that point, it tells the--
or it alerts this person to
actually go see a doctor.
And to me, that is huge.
Now I can look into my
phone and just identify
that I might have
a problem, and I
should go see a
doctor is huge when
I don't have a doctor around
me, and somebody is telling me
I should go do that.
That, to me, is huge.
LISA QUERA: It is.
I mean if I had
my eyesight saved
by looking into
a phone camera, I
think I would feel
it's pretty magical.
And that's the big
myth of machine
learning-- that it's magic.
And I hate to disillusion
you, because we'd all
like to believe in magic,
but it's just math.
It's just linear
algebra and calculus
combined to transform
inputs into outputs.
And here's another
really key concept
we want you to walk
away from today--
that machine learning
is the process
of algorithmically
finding patterns in data.
And we're going to keep--
that word "patterns" is going
to keep coming up,
and we're going
to keep coming back
to the data, because I
want you to think about the
data as the knowledge potential
of what your machine can learn.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: The
concept of machine learning
has been around for a long
time, and the concept,
in general, for deep
learning, I think,
has existed since like 1960s.
LISA QUERA: Yes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So one
of the questions I had--
and I'm pretty sure from
the audience as well--
is, why is it that
it's so important now,
and why is it that people are
working towards it now much
more and are getting excited
about this much more now
versus in the past?
LISA QUERA: Well, there's
three key enablers
that are making all the
difference now, because you're
absolutely right.
A lot of this isn't new.
Now we're doing new
things now, and we're
pushing the boundaries of
knowledge all the time.
But one of the biggest
factors is the data.
90% of the world's data was
generated in the last two
years, and it's coming
from everywhere.
It's structured.
It's unstructured.
It's coming from the web.
It's coming from social media.
It's coming from ERP
systems and CRM systems,
and it's coming from internet
of things and machine sensors
and phones and just a million of
different options for bringing
the data into your
world and representing
human reality via data points.
Now a lot of that data just
sits there passive now.
We're not doing enough
with it, because it
might be in some format that
we don't know how to work with.
But you can transform
that and start
pulling insights and
predictive capabilities
out of that data set.
But if you didn't have those
giant things to learn from,
enough examples
to learn from, we
wouldn't be able to
build these great models.
And the other aspect, of
course, is the computing power.
You can't work with that much
data and these different models
without the compute power.
In 1961, when the
multilayer perceptron
was originally discovered, the
supercomputer, at the time,
didn't even hold a candle
to your phone today.
So it couldn't do anything
with that knowledge.
We couldn't explore it enough.
So now we can.
But of course, what
does it start with?
Data.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Data.
LISA QUERA: "It's not who has
the best algorithm who wins.
It's who has the most data."
And that's coming
from a co-founder
of Google Brain and a
former Stanford professor.
Now why do we agree with him?
Why do we think
that that's so true?
The data determines what
the model will learn.
Remember that it's the
knowledge potential.
If the data does not
accurately, completely,
and fairly represent
the problem environment,
a model cannot find
the optimal solution.
Now, when we talk
about completeness,
what are some of the
things that come into that?
Variety.
So you can't just
train it on examples
of a user behaving in one
way or just a single user.
You need a variety of users,
and you need those users
to behave in a variety of ways.
So diversity of your
dataset is really important.
And then, of course, number,
so that's the complete part
is that we need to make sure
that you have a lot of it.
Now, the second part is
the quality of the models.
So yes, the ideas have
been around forever,
but without the ability
to test those ideas
against large datasets and
with a lot of compute power,
they couldn't identify
the best techniques.
And now we can.
So let's start to drill
into how models work,
and we're going to try to
keep this at a good level.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Are we going
to go into math and formulas
and stuff?
LISA QUERA: A little bit.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, awesome.
The fun part's coming.
LISA QUERA: But the important
thing, again, conceptually--
conceptually, we're
applying weights to features
to calculate an output.
So if we think about how a
human makes decisions, creates
an output, we also do it by
applying weights to features.
Let's think about
looking for an apartment,
and how much weight do you
apply to the parking space?
How much do you apply
to the location?
These are features of the
apartment that you then
apply different
values to in order
to predict which one
will satisfy your need.
Same idea with machines.
Now the difference, of
course, is that machines only
work with numeric
data, so we have
to convert any of our
data points into numbers
to work with.
So if we have an image--
this one is from the
CIFAR-10 data set,
so it's a very common data
set used to test out models,
so you can compare models
across different architectures.
So you take the image, and
you convert it to an array
of the 32 width by 32 height
by the three channels-- red,
green, blue--
and you end up with
3,072 numbers in total,
each of those
numbers representing
that pixel feature.
So that becomes the x in the
function, the input data.
And then we have
these weights that we
start to assign to
each of those pixels
to understand its salience.
How important is that feature
to calculating the output?
And in the end, you end up with
the 10 different labels that
are in that data set, and
you're able to identify
that that's a cat.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
LISA QUERA: So let's think
again about this neural network.
We have the concept of
the input and the weight,
and we start to do a
matrix multiplication--
key term that we're going
to come back to later when
we talk about the
power of hardware,
because matrix multiplications
are compute intensive.
But we have our input, and
then we assign our weights.
That's a product.
And then we add
them together across
the different weighted features
to come up with an output.
We run that output through
an activation function.
Think of the activation function
as being a sorting mechanism.
So you're sort of sorting
signal from noise.
Which of these features
contributes the most
to determining the output?
And once we have that,
then we do a prediction.
So we calculate our first guess.
Now, remember that we
start out knowing nothing,
so we randomly
initialize the weights,
because we don't know anything.
And then we make our
first prediction,
which is probably pretty awful.
We compare it with the
label, and that error,
that difference is
what we use to guide
how we're going to
update the weight, how
we're going to adjust it.
And then we keep
doing that iteratively
across all of these
learning runs,
all of these different
examples, until we've finally
adjusted that weight
to the point where it's
a very accurate representation
of the knowledge
potential and the
reality that we're
trying to capture
to solve the problem
or capture the opportunity.
Now here is a supervised
learning problem,
a simple binary
classification for vision.
But this is the deep part.
So now you have
your neural network.
You have your weighted outputs.
The first layer is just
capturing very simple concepts,
like maybe shading.
You then pass that
to the next layer,
so the outputs of one layer
becomes the inputs to the next.
And that next one
refines the concepts
and turns those shading
into like lines or shapes.
And then it keeps doing
that along the way
so that the lines and shapes
become eyes and mouths.
And then the eyes and
the mouths and the ears
become cats versus dogs.
And then, finally,
you have that output,
understanding the classification
and capturing the label.
Does that make sense?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: It does.
It does.
I think it will be good to go
and visualize this a little bit
for people.
LISA QUERA: Right.
OK, so let's see an
example so that you
can start to see that connection
between data and output.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So we've
chosen this example today
mainly to guide us through the
process of how machine learning
actually works and how a machine
actually takes the inputs,
gets trained, evaluates,
and then predicts.
And I think AutoML Vision
is a great example,
because it helps you visualize.
There are images that are
going into the system,
so it helps you
learn and understand
what is actually happening.
So that's the sole purpose
of taking this as an example.
And we're going to
consider ourselves
to be people who are learning
about clouds to understand
the weather patterns.
So let's consider ourselves
as scientists in identifying
weather patterns.
I have taken some examples here
of images of different clouds,
and they are--
and they're also labeled
with different labels
of the types of clouds.
Now when you hop into
AutoML Vision interface,
the first thing you
see is the images,
which is obviously
Lisa has emphasized
enough about the fact that
data is really important, so.
LISA QUERA: I've never
emphasized that enough ever.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So we go with this--
as soon as we enter
into the interface,
we end up putting data in.
And in this case, it's
the images of the clouds.
Now there are two
ways to enter data in.
One is through
Google Cloud Storage.
You could create a
CSV of your links
to all the images
associated with the labels.
And once you have those,
you could upload that CSV
into the interface, and you'd
have all these images loaded up
in here.
The other way to
upload images is
to just click on this
Add Image button,
and just use the user
interface to actually upload
those images.
So those are the two ways to
get your data into the system.
Once you have the
images in, you'll
also be able to filter and see
the number of images in here.
I think this is important.
If you see, we have large
number of images for cumulus
and cirrus and also--
my god, I can't even read it.
So I'm just going to
avoid it, not reading.
So the last three-- we have
a large number of those,
and then you can see
the ones with the altos
are a little bit less.
And we'll come back to this.
That's why I'm
pointing this out.
So you have this dataset.
Now, once you have
the dataset, you
have the next step,
which is to train
your model using this data.
When we hit-- we've already,
obviously, trained this model,
so we're not going
to do that today.
But when you do it for yourself
with your own image dataset,
you will be able to use the
Train tab to train your model.
And then you could use
options to train it
for a longer period of time
or lesser period of time.
And there are
advantages to training
longer, because the
model would learn better.
Is there anything else you'd
like to add, Lisa, here?
LISA QUERA: No, I think
that's the key point
in the compute time is that
this is also-- remember, compute
hours.
It's not necessarily linear
time, so the two models
that we've trained--
you can see one has a
one hour compute time.
But I believe that was
probably about 10 minutes,
and I think that the second
model, even though it
says two compute hours, because
of distributed processing
and parallel computing,
that, I think,
was only about 15 minutes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
Yeah, so make sure
you select the time,
depending on how good
you want the model to be
and how well-trained
you want it to be.
So after the first two steps
of getting the data in,
training the model, now
we're at the evaluate step,
which is where you're actually
able to see the metrics.
And how do you see the metrics?
There are multiple different
metrics that you can see,
but the one that I'd like
to highlight and point out
is the confusion matrix.
Now, it's not confusing.
It's really just the--
you'd understand why it's
called confusion matrix in just
a little bit.
So when you-- let's
take a step back
before we dive into
confusion matrix.
When you add images into Cloud
AutoML Vision, what it does
is it separates out your images
into training dataset and test
dataset.
LISA QUERA: And it does that
automatically, which is great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah, so you
don't have to do any of that.
You just upload, and it'll take
care of the separating for you.
And in machine
learning for your model
to train on a specific dataset.
And then it's important
that you have a certain test
dataset ready to train the
model that the model has never
seen before.
LISA QUERA: Exactly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And what we
are doing here-- this confusion
matrix is taking that test
dataset, and then predicting,
and then showing you how
accurate the predictions were.
So in this case, we can see
that it was 90%, 94.7% accurate
for the first two
of them, but then we
see a less accuracy
on the actual stratus
one, which was 46.2%.
Now, you also see
that 23% of those
were identified as cirrus.
So this could--
and now this allows
us to actually go
into our dataset
and see what the
problem might be.
And it goes back to
Lisa's earlier point.
It depends on how good your
data is and how much data
you have supplied to the model.
So if you remember,
when we were looking
at the images and their
labels, the ones with altos
were very less, so we had very
few examples of those in there.
So that's why our model's
probably getting confused.
So we may need more data
to support those examples.
And I think that is
the important point
that we wanted to come across,
that data is obviously the key.
You want to make sure that
whatever you want the machine--
your model to learn,
you've provided
enough examples of that in the
dataset for it to learn from.
LISA QUERA: Yes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Right?
And then the next step
is obviously prediction,
and we provide you--
you can see here that the
curl command for the REST API.
The AutoML Vision would
generate a REST API for you
that you could use
to apply into your--
to make this model
for predictions
into either your website
or your mobile application,
whatever it is that you
want to use this model into.
Hopefully, that was
a good starting point
in terms of seeing
how all the steps work
from putting the data in
to training to evaluate,
and then starting to
predict with that.
I'll pass it over to
Lisa to give us some more
information on models.
LISA QUERA: Yes, I mean, I
think the important point
that we wanted with that was
this connection between data
and quality.
Now parameters
are what the model
learns to use to represent
that knowledge potential.
Hyperparameters guide how well
or how poorly the model learns.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hyperparameters, Lisa,
has always been something that
I have struggled to understand.
So if we can take some
examples to help our audience
learn this.
LISA QUERA: Yeah,
hyperparameters--
I've always thought
they should have come up
with a better term, because
it is a little confusing--
the what versus the how.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
LISA QUERA: But a couple of my
favorites are learning rate,
so the learning rate controls
how much you adjust that weight
during each learning iteration.
So as you're going
through the examples,
how much do you change
that weight up or down
to reflect the new
information you
got from the latest example?
The latest error signal that
guided how you changed it--
the learning rate says
how much you change it.
So I want you to
imagine that you
have a huge stack of books to
get through to learn something.
Now you could just skim
through them very quickly
and get to the end.
But you'd probably miss
something important,
and you'd certainly miss
the optimal solution.
Or you could go very
slowly, line by line,
and take notes on each one.
But then you might only
get through a third or half
of the books in
the time allowed.
So you would never
get to a solution.
You need to find the right
learning rate for yourself
as you go through those books.
The model needs the
right learning rate
to understand how fast or how
slow to adjust those weights.
If the adjustment
is too big, then it
could jump right over
the optimal weight,
but if it's too small,
it could take too long
and never converge,
because it'll just
run out of compute time.
So the learning rate
is really important.
Another one that I like
is the dropout rate,
and I like that, because
it seems counterintuitive,
but it's actually really in
sync with how humans learn.
So the dropout rate
is intended to prevent
something called overfitting.
A model that overfits
to the dataset
is a model that has
memorized the data,
so it can't actually
predict anything new.
It would totally fail on
that test set, that something
that it's never seen, it fails.
So we introduce a dropout rate
to basically make the learning
harder.
Periodically, we randomly
zero out some weights.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Just like how a human--
just like how I forget after I
read something in like 10 days,
and I need to go
back and read it.
LISA QUERA: Exactly.
But then you retain
it more, if you
have this interspaced learning.
Well, this works the same way.
So dropout rate is
another really important
hyperparameter.
It can impact the
quality of your model.
So hyperparameters are the how,
and the different combinations
really make a
difference in terms
of data science productivity.
Now the AutoML Vision that
we saw is created by a model,
so it's a model
creating a model,
and that's neural
architecture search net.
And you'll notice that
it's not only more accurate
than the human models--
and these were created by some
of the finest minds in the AI
community.
You've got the best of Google
and the best of Facebook
creating these kind of things.
And you'll notice that the
machine one beat them, and not
only did it beat them
in accuracy, which
is the quality of the model,
but also the operation,
so the amount of compute time
it took, and the parameters.
It's smaller, so it'll be
able to be served faster.
So it's not only more accurate,
but it's more efficient.
The last part of the "why
now" that we want to cover
is the compute power.
So the ideas aren't new.
The data that we've been
getting for a few years,
but it's this ability to
process massive amounts of data
with big, complex
models and a variety
of hyperparameter
combinations that needs
this kind of compute power.
And these models
can be really large.
These datasets can
be so large, it
can literally take months to
process those big datasets
through the big models and to
optimize the hyperparameters
along the way.
So for a data scientist to
wait months for a result
is a huge productivity impact.
So if we could
experiment faster,
then we could create
higher quality models.
And the more compute
power we have,
the more we can
distribute the training,
and the more we can optimize
each training session
to get that quick iteration
and more experiments
that we can run.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So hardware
accelerators basically help
us do the training faster.
LISA QUERA: Exactly, because
they're optimized for that.
So here is training a large
scale machine translation
model, and you can just
imagine the size of that model.
This language is so complex,
the knowledge potential
that a machine would have to
capture would be gigantic.
And in this case, it would be 24
hours being parallel processed
across 32 GPUs, but because
tensor processing units
optimize that matrix
multiplication we saw earlier,
and it's really specialized
for deep learning
and for the math that is
unique to deep learning,
you can compress that
to an hour and a half.
So imagine a data
scientist waiting 24 hours
to get the results
of an experiment
and make another adjustment
or an hour and a half.
Big productivity increase.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, I think we
have learned the model
and the way models work
and the math behind
it a little bit.
But I think it'll be good
for us to understand,
what are the things to keep
in mind as people start
to think about machine
learning and applying it
into their projects?
LISA QUERA: Well,
the first thing
is that the model is really--
it's the most fun piece,
but it's a small piece
of the overall solution.
Data, data, data--
so data collection,
data management,
data understanding
with exploration and analysis
and different feature
engineering to make sure
that your data is accurately
capturing either the problem
that you want to solve
or the opportunity
you want to capture.
You need to represent
it in the data,
and that's going to take
a huge amount of effort.
The model, then, is a
pretty small part of it,
but what's important is
once you have that model,
you want to use it in
your business process,
so that's called
serving the model,
creating the predictions.
And you want to make sure
that you're retraining it
periodically, so you need to
monitor it for its accuracy,
because it can degrade over
time if the reality that you're
capturing is actually changing.
So all of these
are pieces that you
have to think about when you're
wanting to use machine learning
in your business process.
Now some things to consider
are please start simple,
and then add complexity
only as needed.
So try some of the preexisting
models like Cloud AI APIs.
And if that's not getting
you what you need,
then try an AutoML service
where you can make your--
more domain specific
by tailoring it
with your own dataset.
If that's not getting what you
need, you can try something
called transfer
learning, where you
learn from another model to
jumpstart your own custom
model.
And then, finally,
build a custom model
with a custom dataset,
but that will, of course,
take the highest skill level
and the most amount of time.
So you want to do
that only when it
adds real competitive
differentiation for you.
See what you can do with
what's already available first.
Now analyze your
data to ensure you're
accurately and fairly
representing the reality you
want to be learned.
The data is your knowledge
potential, so make sure
you focus on getting that right.
And then make sure
the data features
you use to train the
model are available when
you want to use the model.
So when we talk about accurately
representing the environment,
let's think about predictive
maintenance for a moment
when you might have machine
sensors in the field,
but they're really
impacted by the weather.
So you want to use
weather data to help
make your model smarter.
You want to increase
that knowledge potential,
so you use a weather data
set to train your model along
with the sensor data.
But at the time of
prediction, will
you have that weather
data available?
You need to make sure that what
you train is also what you have
when you want to predict.
Next steps-- there's
so much more to learn,
and I really recommend starting
with the machine learning
crash course that
we have on our site.
We've also collaborated
with Coursera
to create data engineering
and machine learning classes.
There are tons of tutorials
available on the Google Cloud
Platform, and, as
always, there's
Google search for any
topics or white papers
that you might be interested in.
I hope we've piqued your
interest on some things today.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
then if you already
have something going on machine
learning that you would like
some help with from
our teams, then we do
have Google Cloud
account teams that
are available to help you
with any of your projects.
So reach out to them.
And then once you
reach out to them,
if you do require
professional services,
and we have very
high quality partners
that can partner with you
on your project as well.
So we can bring them in and
the professional services
in as needed for your project.
So make use of these
resources, and let
us know what you're doing
in machine learning.
All right, so we're going
to switch to questions now.
And--
LISA QUERA: We'll be back
in less than a minute.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
All right, everyone,
looks like we have
a bunch of questions
from the live audience, so
we'll ask those one by one
and have Lisa answer them.
The first one here
is, "Data seems
to be very critical
to machine learning.
How and where do
I get enough data
to build an accurate model?"
LISA QUERA: Well, first of
all, thank you for listening.
And how and where you
can get enough data
to build an accurate
model is complex,
because it depends on
your particular situation
and what problem
you're trying to solve.
But one thing I would
say is you don't
have to just look inside your
own organization to find data.
Don't forget that you
can enrich your dataset
with other external options.
So there's some
BigQuery public datasets
you can explore to see.
Those are also great for
prototyping and exploring
different model
options while you're
gathering your data
inside the enterprise,
because sometimes it can
take quite a while to put
those datasets together.
And it might be
different people working
on the data and the models,
so if the model folks can
be testing with
some public datasets
while the data folks are
getting all of that collected.
So I would look at
BigQuery public datasets.
Kaggle has a lot
of open datasets.
Academics are often sharing
their work and publishing not
only the model code that
they do but the datasets
they use to train that code.
So those are options
outside of the enterprise.
And then inside the enterprise,
just think about the problem
you're trying to solve, and what
do you believe most accurately
and completely
represents that problem?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK,
that's very helpful.
So the second question
here is, "Can I
still build a good
machine learning model
with a small amount of data?"
LISA QUERA: Again, it depends.
The things that I constantly
repeat are "patterns and data"
and "it depends."
But you can use
transfer learning,
because transfer
learning enables
you to use a sort
of jumpstart model
that has already been
trained on a massive dataset.
And then you can customize it
with a small amount of data.
So when we think
about the example
that Priyanka showed
us with AutoML Vision,
that was a tiny dataset.
That was 1,800 examples--
really small, which
normally, we'd say,
no way can a machine learn
from so few examples.
But because it uses
the NASNet architecture
in the background and a
trained model from that NASNet,
it's able to just tailor the
last few layers of the model
to customize it for
your domain specificity.
So if you only have a
small amount of data,
then you need to start looking
at transfer learning options.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So the key to this
is going back to
some of the things
to consider points
that you made.
Start from what's
already available.
Then look at AutoML
maybe, and then start
to look at transfer learning.
And then if none of those do the
job that you're looking to do,
then you build your
own custom model.
LISA QUERA: Exactly.
And there's things
that you can do
to expand that day-to-day
augmentation options.
But again, bigger
is better when it
comes to the data
part, which leads us
to the second question.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
The last question--
"Is bigger always
better for models?"
LISA QUERA: Well,
there's a trade
off between speed and accuracy,
so it depends on how you define
"better."
What is it that you
want to optimize for?
If you want to
optimize for accuracy,
then it can be that
bigger is better.
But remember that concept we
talked about, overfitting?
Overfitting means
that it can memorize.
If your model is
too big and complex,
it might just memorize things
and not be able to generalize.
So sometimes you need
that sort of little bit
of error in the mix.
And then the other thing
you need to think about
is not just accuracy but speed.
The bigger the model,
then the slower
it will create the inference.
And if latency is
an issue when you're
using that in your
business process,
then a smaller
model might, indeed,
be much better, even if you
do sacrifice some accuracy.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, that's amazing.
Thank you so much,
everybody, for listening.
Stay tuned for the next session.
Bring your teams closer
together with G Suite's meeting
solutions, and thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]